all right
leonard and jerry yeah
you guys grew up where
in this house uh thanks sarah it's been
a long time
and yes for me eight years been in here
eighty years you've been there eight
years
1941
1941.
and you grew up with uh you had mom and
dad
my dad be gone and buried up about
ashbury my mother
married at the moore garden
crosslanes
and you had siblings you had brothers
and sisters
yeah
yeah i'm
nine boys
and six sisters
nine boys and six sisters
some of them's gone
how many of your brothers and sisters
are still alive
yeah there is a very similar emergency
in the event
huh mauricio living in it
i get married
i got a system down
you know where
i just told you
how's the creek ask you to see a house
on this side over here
and
you see that creek
and the water goes up it goes out
and the house set right up there on the
bank that's pretty near now i met the
last time i was out there one time yeah
then her getting hungry
she got
she
did all that she she's in her 60s
what was it like growing up here
you guys went to school and i went to
school
years ago
do you graduate high school no
how far did you guys go in school i went
down i wanted to sixth grade
sixth grade and how about jerry did he
go to school
and i went and went graduating when he
quit
you know when he created great
great
why do you think you didn't go further
in school
i went to the 16
i think
there's
something wrong there
i can't remember i've been long time but
being about our school
you can't figure out what my mother i'll
be out of school beyond screw a long
time
years ago
i quit when i was 15
in the
seventh grade
yeah
and i walked all the way home
in nitro
like in here
all by myself
take my time sometime i will go off the
course and walk back
and that besides the walk but for your
heart too it's about two miles
and for your help
okay
15 or 16 years old now it's going to be
74.
i don't feel that i got to keep my bone
80 and i feel amazed too much yet you're
79 and jerry is 79 now and you're 74
jerry i'll be 74 this coming
october starting next month this might
come and jerry did did you go to school
yeah i was in grade school you went to
grade school how far did you go
not very much i i got i was
15 years old okay
burned my mother over here the baby and
the baby holding the baby
she's 41 years old
she got 9 9 boys six girls
two dead
so you uh tell me about growing up here
what was your childhood like
i can't remember it is
growing up a long time ago
you guys have electricity running water
stuff like that
and how do you get around now do you
drive no have you ever driven i drive no
car in a bike yeah i know how to drive
on you don't know how to drive i kept
the bus down in your store and
pay my bills
you get money from where
the the railroad all of my daddy's place
have you ever had jobs
have you ever had jobs
no i had no job for a long time i
i've been working a long time ago not in
the morning yeah but a long time ago
what kind of jobs did you have
a cat grass for people no
and what about jerry
i did the same thing he does
got grass too
have you ever traveled you ever been
outside of
a long time ago since out of state
somebody
got gone get me and i can't fake name of
the face
it's a long time ago
what were the best years of your life
your favorite memories
no i can't think about what it is
what was the hardest point of your life
i can't remember what it is
so
the way it was explained to me
next door
is that your
you're
one of your sisters actually is your
mother is that right that's one
17 died a long time ago yeah but but uh
one heart what the neighbors told me is
that
i think so that one of your sisters and
your father
are your parents actually
is that right
yeah
that doesn't happen very often but i
guess it does happen not very often yeah
oh so you're this is obviously an older
sister
right mary's the oldest one
i got
uh
old sisters
see i'm
a little bit older than she is she did
them you will
um
see what we call that night down the
river somewhere
you call it
vanilla creek neck creek down here and
there's a house on one side
there
and she live in the house but that one
you have to cross the
the bridge to get to to the house
when it rains it gets up high i i seen
it before i was down there one time
before my sister's down down there i
guess she's still nervous
with me she's my big coach
between 50 or 60 years old so she's one
of your younger sisters huh
this is one of your younger sisters
yeah
it's a big family
and then if i live down
i think if i lived down the river i
think down here somewhere
that
he crossed banana creek that's where
they they needed that i've been down
there one time
and their house said on that side you
stop there you have across the creek not
there to the house that's really nearby
i've been living in a long time is that
right
have you guys ever been in love
you ever have you ever been in love you
ever had relationships
no no no no no ladies
not ever i don't want to be a part of
them
what did your father do for work
working on the railroad
for 42 years i've been talking a long
time for two years
and you're friends with your neighbors
your neighbors are friendly here yes
some
some might
how do you spend your days you you if
you don't drive
you can't really go into town i'm going
to walk down to bother there and get the
best
you take a bus sometimes
yeah
did you have dreams of doing anything
with your life
when you were younger and i'm a long
time ago
long time ago what kind of stuff did you
want to do no
and all kind of kind of stuff
a long time ago yeah
do you have any regrets in your life
no
no regrets
what do you like to do for fun do you
guys
get out and do things do you ever do
anything together or
not very much
sometimes there's something i'm about
how are you two different as brothers
how are you and jerry different
yeah my individuals jerry
how are you and leonard different
i don't
understand
about more different people
if you don't pay me i don't go back
that's right that's what i do too
same
i cut grass for people that's all i do
not still though no you're not cutting
grass now no no
what's important to you guys what do you
mean i can is it money important is is
is
i get many times buy groceries and pay
my bills as well do you have friends
your friends that come by yeah some not
very often anymore yeah
sometime i comment aren't coming down
you guys go to church are you religious
i've been in church with a long time ago
yeah i can't learn nothing now
yeah the world has changed a lot since
you were young yeah that changed a whole
lot now you think it's changing for the
better for the worse it might be a worse
reminder somewhere that way it works
but your life has been good 80 years of
uh yeah living here you say you had a
good game here send me a 90 to be 80
years old 80 years
i want mom nothing next time
[Music]
but you feel like it was a good life
yeah that's how it goes
and jerry how do you feel about the life
you've lived
yeah i need pretty good nights for
people but i want to
that's all i can download
yeah
any words of wisdom you can share
what have you learned in all your
anywhere any anything you've learned in
life that you've you find very helpful
i can't thank nathan
[Music]
all right leonard and jerry thank you so
much for
speaking with me yeah you're welcome and
i wish you the best of luck
living here thank you very much
you